avez-vous déjà rêvé d'être quelqu'un
d'autre quelqu'un de vraiment très
spécial ou est-ce qu'il est passé en
tout cas moi je sais que je rêve souvent
que je suis quelqu'un d'autre bonjour
mon chéri je te jure que j'aurais petra
personnes mais quoi que tu est un super
héros demande doit sécher les cours pour
tester tout est super pouvoirs by sop a
les choses un nom super héros doit être
explicite and boys evatt allemand un
costume à super héros regardez
alors j'ai pas le temps à la maman je me
présente je suis la mouche et comme
toutes ces saletés d'insectes il était
difficile de se débarrasser de moi
mais toi tu peut la sauver le mois bah
ouais c'est ta mission de faire ça
je t'accompagne c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux
il fit fagace toujours tout seul chair
et d'os
mais qui tue on m'appelle m ce boys